the boy I want a couple of with is yeah
man yeah man so the guy I want to couple
up with it Weston so the boy that I want
to couple up with is Eric
[Music]
the boy that I would like to couple up
with is Kushal that's when the Islanders
thought their love could be forever mix
new faces enter dance for all times
we got shake ups breakups and heavy make
out so my this is love after the island
[Music]
hey sexy beaches welcome to love after
the island your official love island
recap show i'm lauren zima here to spill
all the tropical T on this unbelievable
third week of love island airing only on
CBS and CBS all access and joining me in
our cozy Cabana is actress singer and
designer Marie cuoco thank you for being
here breathe and fresh off the sand to
former Islanders we have Mallory santak
here and Kristen McCallister thank you
ladies for being here how are you are
you okay was that tough to watch that
recup Ling uh it's a little weird you
know I wish I was still there but I'm
happy everyone's happy definitely tough
to watch I'm a little salty it's not
just that ocean salts yours no real I
really appreciate your honesty
we're gonna get into all of that
including me who's who of who's with who
after that big tree coupling but first
let's talk about those very good-looking
new faces on the island we had some
people come and go pretty quick what can
we do about it but I want to talk about
some standouts
first of all Kelsey adorable little
blonde her question
got together how did you feel about that
you know Weston and I did not have a
romantic connection so when Katrina came
and stole him you know I was a little
bitter because I wanted to stay there
but I was like you know what did their
connection fine so now that this new
cult a girl is in taking Weston away
it's kind of like come let's make up his
mind like he's had three girls so far so
I don't know I feel about it I hope they
really have a connection and write it
through what do you guys think Weston
and Kelsey like a similar vibe to you
Mallory a gorgeous blonde it kind of
seems like they're this Barbie can
country couple do you think that they
will last it's hard because Weston like
on the speed date he was very intrigued
by me and he knows what to say yeah your
eyes are so beautiful anybody course my
County yeah he puts the Hat up he's like
I just want to look at your eyes I'm
like you know what you're doing it so
then he did the same thing to Katrina X
me feel achy pain do the same thing to
Kelsey just watching the show it looks
like they have a genuine connection but
then again it's hard because he did the
same thing with three other girls yeah
kind of like I'm excited to see where
things y'all well Kelsey does have
beautiful eyes we'll see if they see
right through Weston I also want to talk
about our girl asada
so she came in and wound up with B
Eamonn he was at one point your man yes
and your little salty little softie
I think I started super-beautiful she
seems like a down-to-earth girl you know
what Yaman has a better connection with
her I'm happy for that
it is a little hard though because it
was like that with me okay I'm gonna
tell you though I'm sort of surprised to
hear you say that and I was surprised by
your exit because you did seem so
emotional saying goodbye you said I
really felt like we were building
something within when you kissed him
you were not into the kiss and the kid
says a lot something's triggering her I
was upset because Haman and I had a
great connection he was someone I was
hoping to pursue but the kiss it was
wasn't that great it felt like a
premature like first kiss that we're in
like seventh grade trying to figure out
what lips are it is my tongue go great
you know I'm not gonna lie do you get a
little excited okay let me also ask you
guys and Bree I want to get your take of
someone who you know was an on love
island because I'm watching it when you
guys are spending these first nights
with people thinking what is that first
night like with someone you just met
literally trying to fall asleep with
them what is that like yeah especially
when you don't have a connection with
that person and they think that maybe
there is a connection you're kind of
like oh please don't touch me you please
don't touch me and like wasn't didn't
touch me he was very like respectful but
it's still like this is awkward you just
kinda have to wing it like you have to
realize you're in there for such a short
amount of time you're almost forced to
like see if it happens see if it works
so when I was there I was like putting
my toes against its leg I'm like do like
I don't know if we're gonna work so what
do you still have feelings for human
like when I watch it I do like get sad
cuz I'm like wow like we really did have
a great connection I told myself you
know if he finds someone with a better
connection like I'll be happy for him it
is kind of crappy because you know that
was me at one point but at the end of
the day it's you know I care about him I
think he's a great person and if he
likes someone else more than me then I'm
like
dodged a bullet there it sounds like you
wanted to stay there longer and maybe
meet someone that's a selfie stay longer
all right thanks like sorry - yeah I
would love to stay there longer I mean I
was there over a week and I didn't get
connections anybody there but as soon as
I love that new guy Winston came I feel
like I would I really liked him when
he's not on the show anymore now either
yeah I think he's sliding to that I
think I might have to give it a go
hopefully he sees it when soon if you're
out there check your damn time
the connection might not happen in Fiji
yeah but you don't know what could
happen I love after the island you never
know we saved what I think is maybe the
best maybe just the biggest personality
to talk about for last mr. Eric so Eric
comes in a lot of confidence ladies he
goes for Kira Kira had been coupled up
with Cashel the only thing I liked about
it was his tattoos oh you like the
tattoo but I like the tattoos but I
everything else I'm like we're good here
okay because it seems overconfidence
yeah I love it I'm like whoops
you just came here I know my read on
Erik is he is the guy who on the one
hand is so strongly showing you his
interest and that has to feel good and
that has to be very clear but at the
same time you think is there something
not real about it maybe he's like I need
to go in here and get a girl now like
she's in a couple I gotta break that
couple of so maybe he feels like he
needs to be like really strong and
really forward towards hers like
confidence is sexy in a man yeah when
it's over caring and aggressive it's
kind of like whoa I think he was super
forward I probably would have been very
turned off just by his approach I think
he might mean well but how he came off
was just like so you would have put him
in his play I would have had a heartbeat
been like simmer okay and you were
saying that when you left Kira and
Cashel were so into each other yes her
eyes were you by this turn yeah I was
shocked when she told him you know maybe
this isn't the right thing for us like
cuz when I was there and I left she was
so like me and Kasia like really like
each other like we live 20 minutes apart
from each other in LA like I can't wait
until the show's over and we can have a
real relationship and I was like yeah
get a girl like that's what you're here
for and now she just went and dumped him
I was like hey you just like them like
two days ago so I don't know what
happened you know but I trust her she
was like a great girl and she was very
true to herself so if she didn't feel it
I'm glad she spoke up for herself
I'm at the risk that I'm willing to take
my prediction is Kira might rethink
things with Erik yeah just purely on
physicality the man on love island
you're most attracted to I'm gonna have
to say Erik because I like the touch
here Dylan
Dylan's a hot little blondie
he's very attractive and when you get to
know his personality it's even more
attractive so it's just this ball of
like attraction
I really thought Zach was like super
cute but he was like a little too young
for me but he was so cute like I love
like the dark hair and like his hat to
you right here was so cute let's take a
look back at some of these recouping
moments some faces came and went quickly
but we now have new couples that may or
may not be here to stay so let's talk
about Weston and Kelsey first I want to
play this little moment between Katrina
and Kelsey I don't want to step on
anybody's toes I don't want to like
disrespect you and your relationship you
know what I mean from the very beginning
I said if there's new girls that come in
bro please like by all means like go
like get to know them cuz everyone
everyone in here is trying to find like
the best connection yeah great so I
totally totally get it but what sucks is
that I felt like our relationship was
put on hold I feel like she handled that
well like okay girl go on a date with
your man I feel like she was really
gracious yeah and really great after
watching that clip all I can think about
is the same exact conversation I had on
that same exact couch with Katrina so
I'm dead yeah so I'm kind of just like
okay like you know she's new she wants
to get to know Weston I don't blame her
but that conversation that me Katrina
had I just thought they're like mm-hmm
okay you want to talk to him
great so our girl Katrina who we just
saw in that clip she wound up just
picking Cashel at the end of all this do
we believe in the coupling of Katrina
and Cashel do we think there's hope for
Katrina and Cashel I personally think it
was more in that scenario a friendship
Katrina is a very junior and girl like
you meet her and she has great
intentions so I think with Castle she
felt that he hasn't found that person
yet so I think her reasoning for
coupling up with him was to kind of save
him and give him another chance
I'm awestruck I am in disbelief Keira
apparently disagreed on some level
because she dumped Cashel in favor of
Eric let's take a look about what the
conversation that Eric and Cashel had
before that went down we're not really
talking these days but like three days
ago we was we were tight no yeah it's
it's definitely yeah yeah it's like
reading Braille sometimes
I don't want to act like like I don't
want to pursue things because of certain
things because at the end of the day I'm
here to do me and just just as you are
at the end of the day but like it's all
on her okay Bri you don't know either of
these guys so let me ask you did you
feel like you were watching a mirror
image
that's a perfect way of saying it yes
I'm like okay but they're right like
they're both theirs to do exactly what
everyone is there for so I also
understand that you're kind of gonna do
what's best for you and I where I mean
this is why I could never be on the show
because I'm so sorry watching the show
back now who is the most WTF moment for
you who is the most oh my god I can't
believe this person was saying all these
things and it's a different person than
I thought they were we'll see I mean I
know ain't nobody ain't nobody looking
over my shoulder like dang I wonder what
game is doing I wonder what yeah man
I'm I'm I'm you boys a free bird I'm a
free bird so you thought he was nicer
than he's actually appearing oh my god I
wonder and the reason I even picked him
because I was like I feel like there's
so much more to you there's like this
deep connection and now I've seen him
say you know kind of like what's insane
and doing similar things to these girls
I'm like cool like I mean what am I
chopped liver over here I really like
gaming in the house like he was like he
was so find like joke around with and I
really thought I had a good head on her
shoulders like really good character but
after seeing when he did to Ilana just
totally blindside her it was kind of
like maybe I was wrong maybe you're not
who I exactly thought you were
I mean you left with her her ex it was
so painful to watch what was it like
walking out of the house with her how
emotional was she yeah one it was really
really upset I don't blame her though
she got rocked
speaking of exits let's now look into
the waters of Fiji and reflect on the
Islanders that are no longer able to
look for love these are the goodbyes and
yeah I'm super upset it's hard talking
about it cuz it I feel that even and I
really did go ahead connection so it's
frustrating you know that America didn't
see that but I'm leaving with great
experiences good friendships I'm happy
that you know I met you and I'm happy
with that
yeah I'm good leaving I she cancelled
sorry for her because you're in you're
in there like I was in there a lot
longer than you but for me I just I
didn't find that connection it happens I
think I move a lot sore in a
relationships compared to the guys in
the villa I'm cool I'm I'm actually
feeling pretty good it was pure comedy
I'm balling corner max like ready to go
party and we cool I couldn't have left
though the first part I mean he was in
his leather jacket and Fiji which I
bought a question about just yeah Eddie
was that material isn't really breathing
yeah why were you crying enough oh I was
bawling I was so emotional I think a lot
of it has to do the crazy rollercoaster
of emotions you experience just going in
there you know you're so excited to
enter and then you it's short-lived and
you're upset but just in the moment when
you know you feel like you're cut short
of something that could have been great
alright let's take a look at another
goodbye we were caught by surprise but I
think that America ends I think the
Islanders
they voted against us and I
have to just hold my head up high and
hope that those reasons were outside of
just me being myself
I am very grateful for the experience
I've had a great time I've had some
great people it's been quite a short
journey but it's definitely one I've
told
Winston and be heading him up once he
gets out of here
so no worries on on my end they look
like movie stars they do ScarJo look
alone is great I'm like sweet they look
awesome
you know why didn't those two workout in
love Island it's kind of an interesting
lesson in relationships and the laws of
attraction because inertia was even the
one who won like the best kisser I mean
they're both so attractive why didn't it
work out for them you never know what's
happening on the island and you have to
just push yourself to talk to these
people and make these connections
because your time could end in a hot
second yeah and maybe America didn't you
know think that they had a real
connection yeah our last exit interview
is from Winston take a look I'm still
bummed like I am I'm bummed that it
didn't work out but also I'm like so
ready to get out of that because after
knowing them all for a week of none of
them were for me I wish you know it
would have went
but I mean it's the way the cookie
crumbles so you deal with it you roll on
I'm excited to get home he was standing
there alone at the end I was like this
is the saddest thing I was like oh it's
awful in the music oh it's devastating
I mean Bree as a completely neutral yeah
non Islander do you see the attraction
to Winston yeah you like a tattoo vibe I
do you do I mean Mike he's cute he's got
a very pretty smile gorgeous seventeen
you heard him talk about leaving does
that make you worried shot so more or
less I'm definitely going to okay
reach out to me if to if you want yeah
it's an interview I feel his pain I know
it's frustrating to get in there and get
out and I'd only know how his connection
was with Marley I haven't really seen
that yet but I'm gonna check in and see
how it went
cuz I don't know all right well Mallory
and Kristen we set sail we're about here
are all the crazy moments you weren't
there for
it was good to like touchdow it each boy
that I have always thought is here hey
you know just see what's up hey no no no
I'm not handing out time
[Music]
okay alrighty the competition where they
had to spit food into each other's like
a mom bird her child I mean it was
captivating television but I was gagging
myself court isn't it I couldn't why I'm
like I'm too I'm crazy about hygiene I
just like Oh disgusting when I say
disgusting disgusting like oh the
kissing competition that was fascinating
to me
so everybody's blindfolded your ranking
without knowing who it is how much do
you think you can tell from a kiss I
think a good kissers is an important
thing but I do feel like if you really
like somebody in more times than not the
chemistry is gonna be there when we
guessed right that was a challenge
though that I wanted to do I know I wish
I saw I was like it looks like a lot of
really cool you know some guys in there
that I wanted to kiss and I never got to
did you want to get Mallory I think zach
is so cute but okay let's talk about
Zach you thought he was so cute part of
that montage was Zach and Elizabeth it's
gonna say how's it been in water oh oh
yes they're like the cover of a romance
novel I'll ask you first neutral party
yeah how much are you believing in Zach
and Elizabeth it seems real I certainly
have been there when we feel like in two
seconds that they're your person and I
hope it is what it is
I am so loving them as a couple they're
so cute they seem so into each other but
there was that moment when the new girls
came in and Zach apparently it was like
not freely telling them that he was in a
relationship with Elizabeth I don't know
why sac would do that because he really
was so into Elizabeth like everything he
did not Villa was for her like one time
I was exact why are you not talking he
goes I usually save all my words for a
little bit like yeah literally being
quiet that was so weird
yeah but what's inside is true they
disappeared you're like where are they
and they're up on that balcony talking
and we're all down sighs playing a game
there's so like wrapped up into each
other it's like wild I'm sorry I'm still
on he was saving his words I actually
can't guess I think I'm not Zach you
know his Cindy camera and yeah
personally like when I saw that he
didn't say he was like had a girlfriend
I really don't think it came to his head
I think he's just like yeah like
connections are cool like I don't think
he meant it in a negative way he wasn't
hiding something
no Kevin Elizabeth have a great
relationship I remember trying to like
barge in or other conversations and they
were talking about robots I'm like I
don't even know what to contribute I'm
just gonna let you two so there are two
peas in a pod there were perfect yeah so
weird and I don't know that's cute yeah
all right well let's just kind of make
some predictions right now which couple
are we feeling like has a solid chance
to make it all the way Malorie I'll
start with you two couple of still
Alexander X or my favorite and then
second Elizabeth yeah I have to agree
second Elizabeth I mean they have their
cute waterfall stuff it's hard not to
like believe that but then there is
Dylan and Alexandra and they're like so
down earth and no maintenance humans
that you're just like wow can I have
that were you worried that you're I love
that we're seeing these real feelings
that were seeing these real connections
but as we witness this weekend that REE
coupling we felt good about curing
Cashel and anything can happen anything
can show the shoe on love island all
right everybody we have officially
filled our love tank for this week I
want to give a special thanks to Bree
cuoco thank you for being your Bree and
be sure to check out her new clothing
line cult's la you could follow on
social at cult la look us stylish she is
I love the hair and of course a big
thanks to our beautiful tanned and toned
islanders who are single and available
and deserve the best yeah call me
Kristen McCallister and Mallory santak
thank you guys for letting us a yeah
yeah thanks for having us
alright everybody tune in to love island
five nights a week only on CBS and CBS
all access and join us here every Friday
for a weekly keiki to discuss all the
most major moments from of the show we
will be joined by celebrity guests and
we will have exclusive content you won't
want to miss you can find us as well on
entertainment tonight's 24/7 Digital
streaming service et live at et live.com
order via the eat eat live app and
speaking of apps do not forget to
download the official love island app so
that you can slip right into summers
hottest show from the comfort
from our cozy Cabana here in California
thank you ladies so much thank you thank
you I'm Lauren Zima
stay cool sexy beaches
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]